en 81 secte tu vas devenir extrêmement
populaire avec les débuts de la
collaboration avec tf1 et les débuts du
club dorothée
comment tu as découvert dorothée déjà
parce que j'étais malade j'avais une
hépatite virale j'étais dans mon lit
avait la télé je regardais a mis en
musique cette fille était formidable et
quand j'ai été guérie jde appelé j'ai
dit vous les sentez me dit non voilà tu
as dit alors alors finalement il fait
dire oui avec gérard salesses sur la
commence à faire une série ne sapent les
deux autres prix des chansons et petit à
petit elle a commencé à chanter une
petite chanson elle a pris goût à elle
de qu'elle sentait bien et puis ça a
marché
je suis fan gros bisous bisous j'ai fait
un gros bisou et tu va lancer la
première sitcom française destinée à la
jeunesse avec salut les musclés salut
les musclés alors on va revoir le
générique de salut les musclés et ya
bernard minet qui va venir nous
rejoindre
regardez c'est parti
[Musique]
m
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bernard minet merci bernard d'être là
merci à vous et salut les musclés de 89
84 ans a duré cinq ans
mais oui à prier ou la croisière
foll'amour exactement je sais c'est un
dérivé des muscles et vous travaillez
toujours ensemble parce que je sais que
jean lui qui les quitte pas et les
comédiens avec qui il a réglé dans le
mystère de l'amour puis on se voit
régulièrement
mais voilà ça reste un magnifique
souvenir ah mais c'est magnifique on a
eu beaucoup de chance de le rencontrer
et lui lui et nous a tout de suite bien
fait travailler et puis on a on a essuyé
des plâtres
on a fait le premier site comme donc les
premières première nuit on a travaillé
très tard c'est toi qui as may cry
musclé oui mais avait ensuite j'avais
deux coauteurs mais bon mais c'est toi
qui l'emmène alors témoin oui j'allais
revoir la toute première scène du tout
premier épisode de la toute première
sitcom française c'était les tout débuts
de salut les musclés regarde regarde
regarde mais après personne ne m'abuse
c'est que je me sens et c'est de
concentrer un peu
c'est de tenir ou est ce que tu vas
essayer dernière fois oui mais revient
en arrière fait tout ce que tu as fait
depuis que tu es rentré chez vous et
nous regarder tout regarder mais ma
passion c'était surtout hélène away et
nl et du mans pour demander la
délégation n'aura patrick puydebat qui
va venir nous rejoindre
en plus des muscles et d'un père des
personnages les plus cultes salut les
musclés moi j'étais comme un fou sur
elle j'avais très peu d'années que
j'allais la pécho s'étaient ils google à
la risée de gains sur achats iront même
rappel elle était blonde aux masses elle
est toujours aussi belle opération c'est
vrai et elle s'appelle comment
maintenant elle s'appelle bacsinszky
s'est bâtie sur la pauvre maintenant
même à pas les jaunes et une google
voilà les regarder
je ne savais pas que les nerfs est aussi
trop de manières de se réveiller le
matin j'étais pas très bien réveillé
j'ai eu des visions à bois qu'elle j'en
ai vision ben vous allez rire là dans
l'évier y avait une assiette qui savait
tout seul non tout seul c'est moi qui
l'adav thématique jean gracia nous
regarde qu'est ce qu'elle est devenue ma
copine d'abc elle fait de beaucoup de
demis de d'émissions de cuisine pour le
dette
akon est les conseils et les coaches me
chaque fois que j'arrête de manger il
faut pas venir je suis globalement cela
vous l'écoutez jamais bernard campsas a
arrêté les muscles et mine de rien en 94
est-ce que c'est difficile quand ça
s'arrête et me déjà jean luc nous a fait
travailler jusqu'à la fin nous a gardé
les dix ans d'accord donc c'est très
gentil à lui et après c'est sûr mais
enfin si tu vas à l'époque pour moi
c'est la fin d'une merveilleuse
merveilleuse aventure et une belle
époque d'entre eux connaissent encore
dans la rue baba heureusement tu es
regard des séries 2010 un nouveau permis
n'est bernard minet ouais ouais ouais
non bien sûr e que tu sais il ya
beaucoup de tendresse ils ont grandi
avec nous et non non c'est sympa très
sympa on a beaucoup de chance
moi je dis que c'est un cadeau du ciel
de travailler pour les enfants mais
c'est vrai vous êtes régalés alors après
salut les musclés il ya eu premier
baiser premier pdc la grande série pour
ados ados comment tu as une idée de
premiers baisers tu vas situe alors
c'était très sale dans ses muscles et la
nièce de framboise et qui était justin
qui arrivait par parce qu'il fallait une
petite fille pour un petit peu remué
tous ces garçons steen girard justin
dire elle a grandi et j'ai déjà commencé
à voir des histoires
est ce que je voulais pas jouer
également bah oui il était jeune mais
elle ne rentrait de jeunes artistes âgés
plus plat donc j'ai fait une autre série
avec les histoires de justin
alors il y avait bien sûr annette luc
françois il y avait des jumelles suzy et
suzon oui oui dans un instant drame a
gagné madison avec nous bruno le midd
incité monsieur girard mettrai mon jeu
gira et christophe rippert lui qui était
déjà venu nous voir il ya une loi
regardez ça fait toujours du bien de
regarder le générique de premiers
baisers
c'était emmanuel qui veut absolument la
chanson existait avant l'avant
de série la pécho elle aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
les rats
oui
quatre saisons 78 épisodes eh oui ouais
c'est à quelle heure 7 à 17 18 heures ça
commençait donc l'alerté vers 17 heures
et après s'est passé à 18h 18h30 alors
et merci à magalie madison annette
d'être avec nous merci bruno milan qui
avec l'apache loger bruno aussi gentil
non sans rigoler monsieur girard est
monsieur girard ils avaient ils avaient
la cote 1 monsieur girard fait toujours
d'ailleurs et tout va mais elle avait le
est le beau gosse christophe leur hyper
bien sûr l'udc dans premiers baisers
c'était prof de tennis en plus lui qui
était déjà venu nous voir christophe ont
bien sûr et voilà on faudra qu'on fasse
un phénix ensemble un jour
même s'il a promis dans les forêts
vraiment qu'on joue parce que ces bons
ballons
c'est vrai que quand vous voyez ça c'est
un truc de fou le steak magali tt dia
venus nous voir mais oui mais est-ce que
c'est dur il n'y aura deux d'avoir une
carrière après quand ça s'arrête c'est
ça que mon nom c'était vous étiez
tellement vous êtes tellement sûr dans
la rue on nous appelle encore à naître
ça dépend ça arrive mais quand même
moins souvent mais ça arrive
ouais mais moi j'ai toujours bossé en
fait donc moi ça va après vous avez
bossé après boulot je sais qu'il a il a
tourné après mon pied on m'appelle pas
nette moindre un jour j'aurai moi je
tourne je tourne bien sûr comment vous
êtes arrivé dans le dans sept ans cette
aventure casting tout hasting l'un des
trois castings com comment tu les as
choisi christophe kugler je voulais un
beau mec je le moins bien c'est écrit et
roger roger tu es formidable rôle du
père de gentil sympa et annette et
jeannette elle est arrivée après son
premier casting et elle avait une voix
je voulais quelqu'un piloter je n'ai
quelque chose pas et donc elle est
revenue à daytona dû revenir elle a
inventé la petite voix d'annette qui m'a
aussitôt terrassé alors on a remarqué un
truc dans la série c'est que vous étiez
tous amoureux toutes amoureuses d'un
chanteur c'est ophélie mythe on passe
plus de lui que de l'intrigué regardez
qui était ce chanteur et vous connaissez
tous en l'air il est beau comme en mai
tu vois rogozine
ah oui évidemment ben voilà des garçons
aussi beau croque voisine
ça n'existe pas ou alors sur une autre
planète il est vraiment aussi beau que
ça le beau que roch voisine
au croisic n'existe pas
oui mais il faut dire qu'à chaque fois
que tu rencontres une gamine que je suis
aussi des larves voisine
ça veut dire qu'on est à 4 sur 10
concernant la guitariste guitariste
boisé à l'époque c'était kenji quoi
s'est exercée ça c'est toi qui a eu
l'idée dans le bois d'isle oui c'était
l'idole de toutes les pistes et matt
pokora ce magazine mais avec mila on a
filé venu il est venu de choses dans le
secteur de premiers baisers et annette a
rencontré aux voisines à la housse
coordin savoir parce que christophe toi
je me rappelle est sorti avec toutes les
meufs de la série alors mais sans
rigoler lui c'est un truc de fou lille
sans rigoler et même des mof qui ne
s'est pas dans la série c'est un truc de
ouf je sais pas toi
cbs qui a eu non nous aider les couples
est ce qu a eu des vraies jean-luc je ne
sais pas parce qu'ils ont toujours lieu
qui ne ment pas on essaie
téléspectateurs ont besoin de savoir
honnêtement honnêtement je pense était
une des séries sur le plan des couples
les plus sages
il y avait plus de place pêché ça je
pécho tu es plus sûr est l'année des
gardiens de timbres plus grand c'est
normal la salle à là c'était plutôt
calme gentil c'est que ça me away j'ai
pas qu'est ce qui est à 10h et pourquoi
personne n'est sorti que justin orageux
mais non mais non non mais j'ai fait la
figure pour premier baiser
un jour une demi journée j'étais payé
samson qui quand je me souviens et je
jouais une correspondante italienne eh
bien vous savez à l'image regarder non
ils sont plus de cours que nous
on a je suis pas sûr que ce soit pour ça
que moi
comme elle est plutôt jolie j'avance en
a tout particulièrement lourd
[Applaudissements]
une avancée qui n'est pas tellement si
entre vous et vous j'étais comme des
oufs sur what we genre n'est pas
heureusement parce que je paye tout
comédienne mais voilà c'était bien parce
que je me sens bien dans une agence de
mannequins et ont cherché des petits
boulots et s'était payé donc 500 francs
à l'époque c'était énorme talent caché
et j'avais passé une demi-journée dans
les studios alors ayez une autre
rigolade parcours vous engueuler iessa
se disputer à émettre des insultes qui
fusent et mais sur les insultes on sent
quand même chaud qu'on est sur tf1 qu on
pouvait pas être trop violent mathieu
peut-être que je te prête mes lunettes
pour mieux voir un mois il se trouve que
la femme de ma vie quand on embrasse et
à bandes de mickey jamais fait autant
sept à limonade sur la tête mais faute
sera construit maicon est sorti avec
cette tendace ccra frais en plus tu te
prends pour une gourde ans sébastien
lévesque fait comprendre qu'il suit eu
leur casser la figure et cette bande du
monde plus
c'est sûr c'est pas les bars et c'est
facile même délire tous les hommes
étaient très bien rasé ouais c'est vrai
à l'époque à moi de penser le contraire
et papiers au kenya libéria castaldi
aurait pu quant à l'époque le bloc marc
fait profil bas et ray hé bah tu vois
pas ce qu'il cherchait un mec un moment
qu'il voyait rien non pas du tout marie
delphine est destiné kenya auraient pu y
aller franchement oui et il s'appelle
aussi un sens oui la vole leur grand
mère mais moi j'ai battu les tonga main
mais 194 n'avait que 14 ans je suis
belle lettre ab productions j'étais fier
allé au collège et où oui oui c'est pas
pour ça que maintenant était mineure
ouais c'est pas possible
alors
[Musique]